HANSOL: Hey!
Time for lab.
PHIL: This is probably the
hardest experiment, so--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: So far in 5.301, the
students have learned many of
the techniques that organic
chemists use every day.
Today they'll learn column
chromatography.
It's the last technique before
their original research
project next week.
They are growing more
comfortable in the lab, but
Phil puts their new-found
confidence in perspective.
PHIL: On an average
day in my life,
I'll set up two reactions.
I'll do two extractions
and run two columns.
So when you think about all the
things that you've done
over the past two weeks, the
goal is, essentially, to be
able to do all of
that in one day.
5.301 CLASS: One,
two,three, chem!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: And so it begins.
But packing and running
a column is not easy.
PHIL: Yeah, ideally for this
experiment, you would have one
mentor mentoring each student.
TENGFEI: I'm so nervous
for them.
DAN: Feifei made me
feel like this lab
is much more difficult.
IKE: Hopefully, it's not as bad
as they say it will be.
NARRATOR: Column chromatography
is another way
to separate mixtures.
The students first pack the
column with a special powder.
Then, they load the
mixture on top.
The target molecule is
benzylacetone, and it's
contaminated with guaiazulene,
a dark blue impurity.
As the mixture is washed down
the column, the target sticks
to the solid powder more
strongly than the contaminant,
so the mixture separates into
two narrow bands which come
out of the column at
different times.
As the TAs thought, everyone
is stumbling over the first
simple step.
And the problems just
keep coming.
FRED: The sand staticed itself
all the way up my column, blew
it out the top and
into my face.
TENGFEI: Yeah, this is better.
[Inaudible]
is on the ball.
ANTHONY: I should have turned
off the air, but it keeps
going down.
So the air's not on?
ROO-RA: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: That's not good.
If there's bubbles in there,
you're in trouble.
ROO-RA: It's barbaric.
TENGFEI: You're really bad.
NARRATOR: How do the students
deal with the pressure?
PHIL: And so the silica
gel does not...
[Glass breaking].
NARRATOR: They break stuff,
lots of stuff.
How do the TAs deal
with the pressure?
Feifei gets giddy.
[LAUGHTER]
TENGFEI: Like in Chinese
tradition--
ANTHONY: If we pour together?
TENGFEI: Yeah.
ANTHONY: What does it mean?
TENGFEI: When you are
getting married.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANTHONY: I'm getting married,
apparently.
Take two cups and pour them into
each other-- you wait.
Thank you, finally.
Are you sure that was
10 mililiters?
ROO-RA: Yes.
ANTHONY: Don't steal my--
(SINGING) The whole day
through, just an old--
I'm not going to do
that right now.
No.
She keeps me grounded.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: And Phil?
Phil just goes rogue.
PHIL: You could, like...There
are some people I
would love to [BLEEP]
poke with this.
Just like poke the [BLEEP]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANTHONY: This is exactly
what I want, right?
PHIL: Yeah.
FRED: I'm finally finished.
IKE: Yeah, this collected
my stuff.
NARRATOR: But in end, everyone
runs a great column and
purifies their product.
ANTHONY: My sample is pure.
There are no other peaks where
there shouldn't be peaks.
LINA: Actually, I think my
favorite experiment was the
flash chromatography.
ANTHONY: Even though it was
hard, I felt like, I don't
know, like a chemist, almost.
HANSOL: I liked watching the
column and putting the air
pressure down.
And I loved switching
the tubes.
It was so fun.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANTHONY: Oh, I'm not
wearing my goggles.
That's bad.
I really should have been
wearing my goggles that day.
There's no excuse.
[MUSIC PLAYING]